hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast axon regeneration in the
CNS insights from the optic nerve
presented by Larry Benowitz PhD
professor of Neurosurgery and
ophthalmology Harvard Medical School
neuro surgical innovation and research
endowed professor Boston Children's
Hospital
I am Christina holic of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's
events we are delighted to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
ward at the bottom center of your screen
or use the ask a question box and let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now please join me in welcoming
dr. Benowitz I will now turn the
presentation over to him dr. Benowitz
the floor is yours thank you Christina
for the introduction so I'll be talking
today about ways to get connections in
the central nervous system to rewire
themselves after injury so the inability
central nervous system to rewire itself
has been known for a very long time this
papyrus things back to 1550 BCE and it
describes teachings that go back more
than a thousand years before that so the
Grand Vizier of Egypt
Imhotep extended these teachings about
2700 BCE in other words four thousand
seven hundred years ago so what's listed
here are a number of diseases a number
of medical conditions and the treatments
that I prescribed for them but at one
point he is describing what happens if
there's injury to the spinal cord and as
you can see from the text if you examine
a man with the neck injury fight he was
without sensation in both arms and both
legs unable to move them and he is
incontinent of urine it is due to the
breaking of the spinal cord caused by
this location of a cervical vertebra
this is a condition which cannot be
treated so in the ensuing 4700 years
unfortunately we are still not at the
stage where we can effectively treat
spinal cord injury but we're making
great advances and so the model that we
have chosen to study this question about
CNS repair is the optic nerve so first
let's talk about why it is that the
central nervous system cannot repair
itself first we know that the brain has
a very limited capacity to replace
neurons that have become that have died
this can happen to a small extent and of
course there normally is neural
replacement in certain parts of the
brain the dentate gyrus the olfactory
bulb but in general this doesn't happen
secondly the neurons that have had their
axon severed though the cell bodies may
remain neurons cannot regenerate their
axons over any kind of appreciable
distance in addition neurons that were
not damaged themselves or newer ones
that had their axons damaged
some distance from the cell body have
only a very limited capacity to form
collateral connections that could form
that could be the basis for compensatory
circuits so what I'll be talking about
of these topics is specifically the
issue of axon regeneration so this
doesn't happen for several reasons one
is that we know that after development
neurons lose their intrinsic capacity to
extend axons vigorously this happens of
course when the brain is developing but
not in maturity secondly trophic factors
that might be effective in promoting
growth we know several instances where
levels of those have gone down if the
trophic factors are provided we can to
some extent promote regeneration third
there are many cell extrinsic molecules
that suppress axon growth these are
molecules associated with this scar that
forms at an injury site and with the
mile and debris that's deposited and we
know a number of the molecules
associated with the scar and with myelin
debris that are strong suppressors of
axon growth in addition some neurons die
after their axons are injured and
finally from our own recent work we know
that zinc which normally is present in
all cells and is essential for
biological functioning when the zinc is
liberated and becomes concentration
becomes high zinc in a mobile or ionic
form that can become highly toxic to
cells so as I mentioned our work focuses
on the optic nerve and why would one
focus on this system rather than for
example the spinal cord of course both
are very important functionally for one
thing the optic nerve is the most
accessible part of the central nervous
system though the optic nerve sits
outside of the brain it actually is part
of the brain itself both the retina and
the optic nerve are a part of the brain
itself we know the anatomy the
connections from the eye to the brain
very well
and of course functionally this is a
very important system secondly it turns
out that many or maybe most of the
mechanisms that have been discovered in
this system have turned out to be highly
relevant to the spinal cord in other
parts of the CNS so the optic nerve has
really served as kind of a discovery
platform for understanding why
regeneration fails and discovering ways
that we can reverse that that failure so
qahal the great proto neuro scientist
himself used the optic nerve as a model
system to study CNS regenerative failure
so this is this image on the on the
right comes from Kyle's magnum opus his
third magnum opus after describing the
histology of the nervous system the
development of the nervous system he
turned his attention to injury to the
central nervous system and here he's
showing an example of an optic nerve you
could imagine the retina up to the right
and and and he'll be showing at the
injury site using the Golgi stain which
impregnates just a small fraction of all
cells and their entire dendritic tree
and axons what you're showing at the
injury site is that the damaged axons
form these retraction bulbs they can
show kind of what he calls frustrated
axon growth reformation of growth cones
but it doesn't go anywhere so this of
course is paradigm addict - what happens
throughout the entire nervous system I
found this very nice image of qahal and
his students on the web and this person
here Te'o was the person who carried out
the following experiments so what Te'o
did was to sever the optic nerve and of
course there would have been no
regeneration through the native
environment of the optic nerve itself
but what he reasoned was that since
regeneration does occur in the
peripheral nervous system maybe
regeneration has something to do with
the extracellular environment
that the axons are growing through so
what he did was to essentially swap out
the removed the optic nerve distal to
the injury site and substituted the
animals own sciatic nerve a fragment of
the animals own sciatic nerve and
astonishingly some of the damaged axons
here at the injury site grew right into
the sciatic nerve graft and this line of
investigation was then pursued
aggressively by Aguayo
and his colleagues in the 1980s 1990s
the wire was at the Montreal
Neurological Institute McGill University
and this these studies carried out in
much much greater detail and much more
systematically this basic paradigm so
you damaged the optic nerve just behind
the eye and then you effects the cut end
of the optic nerve a autologous graft of
the animals own sciatic nerve so this is
threaded up over the brain and targeted
down into the superior colliculus one of
the primary target areas that the retina
would normally innovate in the brain and
what was found is that a few percent of
the retinal ganglion cells were able to
grow axons all the way through this
peripheral nerve graft and form these
synapses here in the superior colliculus
so this was really a big deal this was
really the first systematic
demonstration that you can get some
degree of regeneration of axon
regeneration in the central nervous
system and studies like this were
carried out by Aguayo and his colleagues
in the spinal cord and in other parts of
the central nervous system and indeed
this held up so why is it that neurons
are able to regenerate axons that is to
some extent through the environment of
the peripheral nervous system but not in
the environment of the central nervous
system itself and so this question was
picked up by Martin Schwab who has
become one of the world leaders in the
in the issue of neural reorganization
CNS regeneration effects
of of activity on axon growth but in
these experiments published in 1988 what
what schwäbisch colleagues did schwab
occur oniy in this case was to take
neurons from the superior cervical
ganglion peripheral neurons approval
sympathetic neurons and grow them in a
dish in the presence of either
oligodendrocytes the glial cells of the
central nervous system that formed that
formed the sheath around axons the
myelinated Lea of the central nervous
system compared to either astrocytes in
this case or compared to peripheral
nervous system achieving cells that is
Schwann cells and if we look down at the
bottom first what we see is that these
neurons there this is a phase contrast
image are extending their axons happily
over the environment of a an astrocyte
you need to see the same thing if if
they were allowed to grow over Schwann
cell we are as if put in the environment
of these oligodendrocytes the myelin
forming glia of central nervous system
the axons assiduously avoid these these
type of glia the oligodendrocytes the
CNS on a tender sites so this was in a
very important discovery that the glial
environment of the central nervous
system is inhibitory to axon growth
whereas astrocytes or the glial
environment the peripheral nervous
system are supportive to growth and
subsequent backward Schwartz labs you
straight modern a number of other
investigators Jahangir my neighbor here
Children's Hospital the late Marie
Philbin Lisa character
Jerry Jerry silver many others
contributed to this discovery of the
molecules associated with myelin and
molecules associated with the scar that
forms in an injury site that are
responsible for suppressing axon
regeneration so we know that myelin has
associated with protein spoiled no-go
violence acidic lipoprotein alga that
decide myelin glycoprotein these act
upon some common receptors shared
receptors as well as their own distinct
receptors and these receptors in turn
convey a signal intracellularly that
converges in general converges on this
small gtp ace called Rho a and a
signaling through grow a in turn
activates other downstream signals
leading to the collapse of growth cones
and the arrests the backs on growth the
the scar that forms at an injury site
some of the primary molecules associated
kiss in addition are carrot and sulfate
proteoglycans in chondroitin sulfate
proteoglycans they also act upon
multiple receptors what's shown here is
one of their receptors PT P Sigma but
they also act on the noble receptor as
well and divers boot found and so the
damaged axon has lots and lots of
impediments to regeneration we know
several ways to overcome these
impediments we know that introducing the
bacterial enzyme c3 of our fossil
transferase causes rho a to undergo a
irreversible change
so essentially Rho a is knocked out
which comprehensively counteracts many
or all perhaps of these extracellular
suppressors of axon growth and then
other people including taganka my
neighbor here developed the dominant
negative form of the no-go receptor that
will bind all of these ligands but parts
that are missing so it doesn't convey a
signal or downstream signal to activate
Norway so in cell culture either
introducing c3 whereabouts of
transferase or introducing a dominant
negative form of the no-go receptor
allows neurons to extend axons provided
you supplement the culture medium with
appropriate trophic factors however in
vivo that is not sufficient to cause any
kind of regeneration
so here I'll introduce the optic nerve
model these old parts of longitudinals
at the optic nerve the injury site is
shown with the asterisk over here the
sections are stained with antibodies to
the growth associated protein gap 43 and
what you see here is that at the site of
excellent injury this is a crush of the
optic nerve so we see some gap 43
positive nerve terminals accumulating at
the injury site and not much and
absolutely no growth extending beyond
beyond the site as would be expected
from the early work going back to Kahala
and Aguayo and many many others if we
introduce a gene encoding the dominant
negative form of the nova receptor into
the into the projection neurons the way
another breton or ganglion cells
this too is insufficient to cause any
kind of appreciable regeneration or if
we introduce the c3 enzyme again using a
virus Havey at no associated virus
encoding the c3 muscle transfer asus2
does not give us regeneration so this is
essentially telling us then that
counteracting the cell extrinsic
suppresses of axon growth in general is
not sufficient to give us regeneration
so why is this and of course one reason
is that we've done nothing at this point
to activate the intrinsic growth
capacity of of the damaged neurons so
one could imagine that the experiments
of counteracting these cell extrinsic
presses of axon growth would be like
trying to drive a car by taking your
photo off the brakes and of course
that's helpful but it's not helpful
unless you also step on the gas so a
very important discovery was made by
Martin berry who was working in London
at the time this is a paper published
over 20 years ago and what Barry did he
he had a different take on those
experiments the peripheral nerve graft
his reasoning was that perhaps the
reason that perhaps the reason that his
peripheral nerve grafts were causing the
damaged neurons to regenerate their
axons was that these peripheral nerve
grafts might be putting out some kind of
some trophy
factor that stimulates the retinal
ganglion cells and that's the key to
getting them to regenerate axons so what
what Barry did here was to damage the
optic nerve the crush sites shown over
here and in controlled conditions of
course he gets no axons regenerating
distal to the injury site so this is
debris shown over here he speckles but
no continuous axons extending beyond the
injury site this is also with Jeff
weakly immuno state however he saw
something remarkable when he put a
fragment of peripheral nerve into the
back of the eye and what happened here
was that suddenly he got lots of axons
for generating beyond the injury site so
this was a really exciting finding this
was the first evidence of extensive
regeneration in the central nervous
system through the environment through
the native CNS environment itself and of
course Barry's take on these studies was
that the cells of this peripheral nerve
graft presumably the glial cells the
Schwann cells the in sheathing cells
were producing some trophic factor that
stimulated axon growth from the from the
damaged neurons the damaged retinal
ganglion cells so our group got into
this into this area about this time we
were previous he's studying optic nerve
regeneration in lower vertebrates fish
frogs are able to regenerate they're out
there spontaneously throughout life we
were trying to understand how they did
that but in in those studies we were
taking the retinal ganglion cells the
projection neurons of the retina of fish
growing them in culture and trying to
understand what it was that enabled them
to regenerate their axons so from that
work we identified some active molecules
and we tested them based on various
findings that there's something that's
producing a generation we tested them in
the mouse our first studies we've done
in the rat in the case of the rat optic
nerve injury so as many people before us
had found you
to the optic nerve and you got no
regeneration distal to the injury site
and then starting a couple of days after
injury and extending through the next
month the proximal portions of the
damaged axons die as do the cell bodies
themselves the retinal ganglion cells
including any possible possibility of
recovery we then try to see what
happened when we injected this molecule
that we were studying in lower
vertebrates and what we found in that
case we entered the optic nerve made our
intraocular injections and to our
surprise we discovered that these
injections caused the retinal ganglion
cells to go into an active growth state
and begin regenerating their their axons
just as Martin berry had found however
to our initial disappointment what we
found is that even our control
injections did the same thing so this
was kind of distressing but we then went
on to find that what we hadn't
appreciated was that unlike humans the
lens of the mouse or the rat eye is very
large and so if we weren't careful in
our injections we would Nick the lens
this itself causes an inflammatory
reaction and that turns out to be the
key just causing this inflammatory
reaction this influx of cells from the
innate immune system is in fact the trek
to get intraocular activation of the
retinal ganglion cells in a paper we
published the 2014 mark Fisher's first
elephant we found that these kinds of
inter ocular injections
we're causing the retinal ganglion cells
to revert to an active growth state and
turn on genes like gap 43 and others
that are associated with active axon
growth and along with that they extend
their axons through the through the
optic nerve so we then went on to grow
inflammatory cells in a dish
collected the proteins that they secrete
into the medium and from that work you
Chen Yin in my lab discovered a novel
growth factor
uncle modulate it's a small calcium
binding protein never previously known
to be made by inflammatory cells and
that were previously known to stimulate
axon growth so here we're staining these
cells these inflammatory cells they get
from the eye if to reducing inflammation
in this case using a substance called
thymus and without injuring the lens
these cells were looking at here while
the neutrophils the first responders of
the native moon system and what we see
is that the neutrophils are making very
high levels of this protein that we
identify this protein anka modulate if
we look at the retina bite
immunostaining what we see is that the
normal retina shows almost no uncle
module in we are as if the reducing
intraocular inflammation buys Imus and
we get very high levels of this protein
we see the same things at the that the
mRNA level almost no uncle module in
mRNA found in normal eye whereas after
inducing inflammation levels of the
message go sky-high and then in
gain-of-function experiments carried out
in collaboration with lab at MIT we
packaged these uncle module and we also
found that uncle module and in order to
be effective required elevation of
cyclic am P the elevation of cyclic am P
causes the uncle module and receptor the
receptor for uncle module indirect
retinal ganglion cells because that
receptive translocated to the cell
surface
so uncle module in can exert its effect
so these experiments have done together
with Bob Langer from MIT and what we
found is that unlike the control
condition when we injected beads that
that slowly released alpha module in a
cyclic a and P analog we got the same
result as Martin very that this
extensive axon regeneration distal to
the injury site and here in loss of
function experiments
Yuchun discovered that a small peptide
representing the n-terminal of uncle
module in acts as a an antagonist it
prevents the native molecule from
binding and so you can cause
ocular information introduced this a
small peptide antagonist banca module in
and get no regeneration so this is
telling us then that this protein of the
module in is being made by inflammatory
cells and is a very potent stimulator of
exon growth what we also discovered was
going back to Martin Berry's original
paper he reported that his grafts that
he had put into the back of the eye were
in fact filled with inflammatory cells
and subsequent to this point I think
that Berry has come to feel also that
his discoveries are due to inflammation
the induction of an inflammatory
reaction in the eye of course this isn't
something that can be used clinically
but molecules like on the module and
delivered through slow release polymers
or by viral gene delivery are turning
out to be to be quite effective in
animal models so now when we combine the
the treatments that I mentioned before
the dominant negative no-go receptor or
the c3 muscle transferase to inactivate
that ro a that common signaling element
that all or most extracellular
suppressive acts on growth converge on
this is the same material I showed you
before but if we now activate the
intrinsic growth state of the retinal
ganglion cells we're able to get so much
regeneration down the optic nerve that
we can't even find the injury site any
longer so this is a combination of
inducing intraocular information plus
introducing that c3 protein into retinal
ganglion cells to inactivate row a so
and about a little after we published
that work dugong my neighbor here at
Children's Hospital made a very
important complimentary discovery and
that is that another way to get
extensive axon regeneration was to
tinker with the internal state of
retinal ganglion cells so we were
actually causing regeneration by
introducing a atrophic agent uncle
Magellan and that we had found partially
activate several of the most important
signal transduction pathways in the cell
it activates the so called pi3 kinase
pathway that in turn activates a KT and
important downstream molecules it
activates the map kinase signaling
pathway and it may also activate the so
called jak-stat signaling pathway so
this uncle Madeline is acting through
multiple cell pathways to cause axon
growth but what Jagan has group
discovered Kevin Parke was the first
look with that paper was that the the
signaling pathway still have important
breaks on them so as neurons develop
they are up regulating suppressors of
axon growth cell internal cell intrinsic
suppressive acts on growth so these take
the form of p10 best known as a tumor
suppressor gene p10 suppresses cell
signaling through the pi3 kinase Akt
pathway and what park and and Giganta
found was that if you defeat the gene
for p or p 10 in retinal ganglion cells
that will cause about the same amount of
axon regeneration or maybe a little more
axon regeneration then uncle module in
plus elevation of cyclic a.m. P but we
ask the question what happens if we
combine these treatments in other words
delete the p10 gene and introduce
intraocular inflammation or introduce
Onkel modulate plus elevated cyclic AMP
II so one cut possible outcome could
have been that these are just
overlapping with each other you won't
get any more regeneration than either
one alone or perhaps there would be some
ant activity or even synergy in the
sense that the uncle module in is
partially activating cell signaling
pathways they still have breaks on them
but if you then remove the p10 gene you
might get some kind of a Nativity
synergy synergy and in fact what we
found was a remarkable synergy between
these two treatments closing about ten
times more axon regeneration that either
treatment alone and so here now with our
injury site remember the normal state
would be no acts of regeneration
whatsoever distal to the injury site
here we're staining the regenerating
axons with with red using anterograde
tracer and what we're seeing is lots of
regeneration regenerating axons all the
way down at the end of the optic nerve
and what we find is that some of these
axons become myelinated meaning they're
able to conduct signals efficiently this
this part of the work was all headed by
Sylmar at de lima who did fabulous work
and is now still in lab continuing with
some of these questions in addition some
of these axons navigate to the
appropriate target spots so here we are
in the dorsal lateral geniculate nucleus
and some of the regenerating axons here
in their terminals in red in the dorsal
lateral geniculate nucleus and we can
double stain these terminals with
antibody to the particular glutamate
transporter the glue to a marker for the
terminals of retinal ganglion cell axons
and we're seeing that these axons are
informed the factor forming synapses and
we have a little bit of evidence that
some functional recovery is taking place
but not a great deal so here is Samara
and Yoshiki Koriyama who was the second
author of this paper and I should also
mention Taguchi kurimoto who worked on
this and earlier stages of the
combinatorial treatment to the left so
this was good news in the sense that we
could get some axons for generating the
full length of the act of the optic
nerve and and we innovative target areas
but the bad news was that the extent of
regeneration still remained very low
maybe 1% of all the retinal ganglion
cells were successfully regenerating
down the optic nerve and just the
percentage of those were innovative
central targets so the question then is
why is it that most of the retinal
ganglion cells are
it's regenerating the Roxxon snap down
the optic nerve but at this point I
teamed up with my colleague Paul
Rosenberg who is is extremely
knowledgeable in many areas of
neuroscience but he had also done some
work on the biology of the sink which I
just mentioned briefly in the
introduction so why zinc so we know that
as I mentioned that zinc is present in
all cells neurons and all other cells
it's an essential part of protein
structure so many proteins for example
zinc fingers opal zinc finger
transcription factors utilizing to allow
the three-dimensional folding of
proteins so that they're able to bind to
their targets appropriately numerous
enzymes contain zinc often in their
catalytic site again allowing for the
structural coordination and activity of
the protein pumps so that sink is
covalently bound to proteins however
there's also a very very low level of
sell it in cells of sink that's in a
unbound in an unbound state that's
called mobile sink or ionic zinc or
freezing and that zinc is held to very
very low 10 to the minus 10 molar
concentrations by an elaborate series of
zinc transport protein zinc import
proteins zinc buffering proteins so the
cell has very elaborate molecular
machinery to maintain zinc levels at
appropriate levels but one exceptions
that is in synaptic vesicles and so it
turns out that there is protein called Z
n t3 the zinc transporter protein 3 here
is just a little bit from a review
article about the biology of saying the
neurobiology of zinc and this are the
the abstract ends with this kind of
they're humorous but but really
interesting quote however the number of
normal biological functions health
implications
and pharmacological targets that are
emerging for zinc indicate that if I
turn out to be the calcium who 24 a
century so the point here is that while
there has been so much attention focused
on the neurobiology of calcium zinc is
kind of coming up from behind may not
overtake at that calcium but extremely
important for neural function so the
proteins EMT 3 illustrated here around a
synaptic vesicle is the protein that
transports zinc from the cell celled
cytosol cytoplasm into the into synaptic
vesicles with a about a let me think you
about a millionfold concentration of
zinc from the extracellular from the
extra-extra vesicular space into
synaptic vesicles and that's illustrated
here and then the zinc in synaptic
vesicles is co released with classical
neurotransmitters like glutamate goes
out into the extracellular space and
normally under normal circumstances just
modulates synaptic function so zinc is
actually regulating NMDA receptors and
it's essential for long-term depression
and plays a major role in long-term
potentiation as well so this is a normal
part of synaptic physiology the zinc
that's Co package with glutamate or
other neurotransmitters but in
pathological states that zinc level can
go into the zinc gets high in zinc
levels become very high go into the
postsynaptic neuron and wreak havoc and
in fact in a very important study
published in 1995 or 96 by Jayco and
Dennis Choi showed in fact in hypoxic
ischemic injury it's the entry of zinc
into the cell that is probably the
primary culprit for causing cell death
and more recent studies indicate that
it's kind of a collaboration between
zinc and calcium that's responsible for
cell death in in stroke a hypoxic
ischemic injury so let's get back to the
model up but before you
let me just show you how much zinc there
is in the brain so it was known for a
very long time that parts of the
hippocampal formation I here in the
highlights of the hippocampal formation
extremely high levels of zinc this sake
is visualized using a reaction of but
zinc when it becomes three when it's no
longer covalently bound zinc is reacting
with sila night that's introduced into
peritoneal intraperitoneal a into the
animals forming this precipitate that's
then enhanced by a silver reaction so
you see this extraordinary level of zinc
not only in the hippocampal formation
but throughout the neocortex so all of
this is representing zinc in synaptic
vesicles Co packaged along with
glutamate here in the amygdala caudate
putamen very little in the cerebellum
and then many other brainstem structures
so let's go back to the retina now so
here we have one of these wonderful
drawings from the hall showing the
layers of the right now I flip this over
puss in our work we typically show the
projection neurons that send information
out from the eye to the brain the
retinal ganglion cells we show up on top
so light comes here from the top
Pierce is right through the retinal
ganglion cells pierces through the inter
neurons hits the distal segments of the
rods of the cones the photoreceptors
signals from those cells then are passed
along through their cell bodies onto the
horizontal cells and the bipolar cells
the bipolar cells are the excitatory
inter neurons of the retina and
interposed in the circuitry are the
inhibitory interneurons the amacrine
cells the Amoco cells are extraordinary
they were thought to be 50 to 70
different types of alacant cells perhaps
40 30 to 40 different types of retinal
ganglion cells maybe 15 types of the
excitatory inter neurons bipolar cells
so it is extraordinarily precise
circuitry the retina itself is a
computational device that's taking the
photic information from that hits the
photoreceptors
pierce through this extraordinarily
complex circuitry of the inter neurons
and then projects this information onto
the ganglion cells which are then
sending different channels of visual
information back to the brain through
the through the optic nerve I should
mention also that retinal ganglion cells
themselves maybe 10% of them maybe it's
higher than that are intrinsically photo
recessed photosensitive and in addition
to receiving information through the
well-known retinal circuitry are
themselves responding to the overall
illumination and those cells are
responsible for regulating our circadian
activity as well as the pupillary light
reflex okay so let's look at the retina
after optic nerve if the optic nerve is
injured so here we're visualizing sync
as shown in that previous image using
the solenoid reaction and again we're
not looking at the covalently bound zinc
because our sensors the zinc sensors
don't pick that up is too tightly bound
to proteins the sensors are only picking
up zinc that becomes available in this
mobile or free state so the normal right
now with ganglion cells up shows very
little zinc staining a little bit in
this so-called outer plexiform layer
where the retinal inter neurons receive
inputs from the photoreceptors but very
little happening up here so what what
did we expect after we injured the optic
nerve we might we might have imagined
that perhaps level of perhaps levels of
zinc might go up the damaged neurons in
the retinal ganglion cells and in fact
that's not what happened but we were
pretty astonished to see what did happen
so let me introduce here Eric King Lee
who worked in the lab for five or six
years and was absolutely spectacular we
tried to chain him down but he just went
back to China and took an associate
professor position in in Guangzhou and
leading eye Institute of China anyway
what what Eric found I should mention
that all of this work was so supervised
that would paul rosenberg and myself
steve lip art at MIT professor of
chemistry
with some spectacular work in inorganic
molecules in biology must go well
through this work as well and what we
found then is that one day if they're
injuring the optic nerve we did not see
Cinco up in the retinal ganglion cells
but we saw this extraordinary elevation
of 3 on mobiles ink happening in the
synaptic layer of the retina this is
where the retinal ganglion cell
dendrites are receiving it but from the
inter neurons Steve lavars lab developed
this wonderful fluorescent zinc sensor
that gives us better temporal and
spatial resolution than this so-called
photo metallography to see menarche
actually and with zp1 what we're able to
see is that the zinc from this normally
low-level here we're focusing
specifically on this zone the inner
plexiform layer the synaptic zone the
levels go up even within an hour we have
evidence that it goes up within a
half-hour so that's probably earlier
than any pathological change that's ever
been described in the red map so the
levels of zinc continue to rise here at
6 hours at one day and then levels go
down in the synaptic zone at two days or
three days after injury but the zinc
that transits over and collects in the
retinal ganglion cells themselves here
enlarge is a retinal ganglion cell we've
done double stinging and the various
other ways to show that in fact this is
a retinal ganglion cell where the with
the zinc ends up here I'm introducing
two key laters these are small molecules
that bind up zinc and remove it from the
from the scene so one of them is a well
known zinc he later T pen with extremely
high affinity to zinc over calcium and
this other one cx1 also developed the
layup of steve lombardi as a a high
affinity for zinc but no affinity for
calcium so those will come in in a
moment and again bringing back znz three
the protein that transports sink into
synaptic as
what we see is that the normal retina
here in this synaptic zone a zone with
only very modest levels of Z and T 3 but
one day after inducing optic nerve
injury just as the levels of zinc go up
levels of these ink transporter go up
and the two are interdependent of each
other so in other words as zinc goes up
levels of the CNT 3 protein go up and
that CNT 3 protein then is what enables
that that zinc to become sequestered in
synaptic vesicles and subsequently
exocytosed to go over to the retinal
ganglion cells so what happens if we
delete the gene this' ENT 3 so here
first are the wild-type littermates of
animals that have the c mtq gene missing
these guys have the gene present and so
they show the expected elevation of zinc
here in the synaptic zone Wednesday
after optic nerve injury and the
expected transit of zinc an accumulation
of ret into with the retinal ganglion
cells
three days after optic nerve injury
whereas with the knockout of the gene
both disappear so the zinc it is still
being elevated by upstream steps that
I'll tell you about in a minute but it's
not sequestered in synaptic vesicles and
we're not seeing higher accumulations
therefore in this synaptic zone nor are
we subsequently seeing at 3 days much
accumulation in retinal ganglion cells
some but much less by double
immunostaining for this zinc transporter
proteins we can zinc transporter
proteins an c3 we can double stain for
markers for different types of
interneurons and what we find is that
the Z and T 3
Co stains with begat begat is the
vesicular gaba transporter that's found
in the terminals of the inhibitory
interneurons so this is telling us that
the initial accumulation of zinc is in
the terminals of the inhibitory
interneurons the retina the amacrine
cells so this is pretty surprising
what's what's causing this to happen if
we delete the CNT
rejean it turns out that that alone is
enough to greatly increase the ability
of retinal ganglion cells to survive
after optic nerve injury so normally
after the optic nerve is injured if we
wait two weeks we've lost about 80
percent of the retinal ganglion cells
that's shown here only about 23% of the
retinal ganglion cells surviving two
weeks after optic nerve injury but all
we need to do is to knock out that
transfer the gene for that transporter
protein CMT 3 and we doubled the
survival of retinal ganglion cells and
even more surprisingly that alone gives
us some optic nerve regeneration so this
is telling us then that this
accumulation of zing in the inter
neurons is one of the main reasons that
retinal ganglion cells die if their
axons are injured and it's one of the
reasons that retinal ganglion cells
cannot regenerate their axons after the
optic nerve is injured we can also
approach this pharmacologically so I
mentioned the key lehder T pen and zx1
before and so we here is the normal
complement of retinal ganglion cells two
weeks after their vin jury the numbers
of cells have gone way down we have
selective survival of some of these
large cells but the numbers as you can
see here for me to go way down and again
either one of these key Lakers team NOC
x1 strongly increases the ability of the
ganglion cells to survive and looking at
nerve regeneration here's our negative
control the injury site no treatment no
regeneration and either of those
incubators causes extraordinary levels
of axon regeneration so this was
discovered again by Eric King Lee the
same paper that reports all of that so
that was pretty remarkable and of course
raises a number of questions one is why
is this elevation of st. causing the
cells die why is it suppressing axon
regeneration and what's happening here
in the retina after we enter the optic
nerve why is this zinc level going way
up so we know from previous work in the
field that
Z or I'm sorry that that zinc can be
liberated from a protein Mattel a
thiamine that normally buffers zinc and
other divalent cations so nitric oxide
or reactive oxygen species can react
with the telethia T and displace the
desync that's bound to methyl Authority
giving rise to ionic or freezing nitric
oxide itself comes through is formed by
the enzyme nitric oxide synthase there
are three forms of aid in the retina the
primary one is the neuron specific NOS
also called nos 1 and so nos 1 converts
l-arginine to nitric oxide and
citrulline this nitric oxide then reacts
either by itself or perhaps it reacts
with oxygen first the form peroxy
nitrite reacts with metallo thymines it
gives rise to this freezing and so if we
knock out the gene for nitric oxide
synthase one neuron specific nos 1 what
we find here are the wild-type
littermates the expected elevation in
the retina one day I felt that nerve
injury the elevation at 3 days in the
retinal ganglion cells we knock out the
gene for NOS 1 and we no longer see this
zinc elevation so this is telling us
that the upstream step to zinc elevation
is elevation of nitric oxide in the
retina and here in these lower panels
what you see is using a sensor also from
the live art lab a sense of a nitric
oxide free nitric oxide we see that the
normal control retina has only very low
levels of nitric oxide the you nitric
oxide Center sensor is called FL 2 forms
a copper complex and this is kind of an
amazing molecule and so one hour after
optic nerve injury who sees
extraordinary elevation of nitric oxide
Wednesday after optic nerve injury
persists and then three days after optic
nerve injury it goes even higher and
then begins the decline at five days
so this nitric oxide then is responsible
for the elevation of zinc that occurs in
the retina has to post optic nerve
injury we had imagined that perhaps the
nitric oxide is a signal between the
injured retinal ganglion cells and the
and the inter neurons and maybe that's
how the zinc becomes elevated the
retinal ganglion cells increase their
production of nitric oxide and that goes
into the Amoco cells causing the amercan
cells through these the zinc but in fact
that's not what happens what we find by
a new staining and also confirming work
that had been reported by other people
in the field before us the nitric oxide
synthase itself is only found in
advocate cells so this is telling us
that there must be another upstream
signal coming from the granite from the
retinal ganglion cells activating this
population of of amacrine cells giving
rises bursts of nitric oxide giving rise
to this elevation zinc this confirms
that the nitric oxide is in amacrine
cells this is a marker for an open cells
pax6 whereas a marker for bipolar cells
bsx - does not Costain with with the
with the nitric oxide synthase so if we
delete the gene selectively in a merkin
cells we got from Paul Wong at MIT we
got animals with a conditional deletion
of the das1 gene because those with mice
expressing the the Curie recombinase
enzyme - not the gene out specifically
in emigrant cells expressing the
vesicular gaba transporter so here we've
knocked out the gene and what we find of
course is if we knock out the gene in a
merkin cells we lose this elevation of
zinc so what we have to do is prevent
amalgam cells from producing nitric
oxide synthase and you get this this
loss of this same signal with a very
dramatic increase in the survival of
retinal ganglion cells so let me go on
this this summary diagram and what we're
discovering is that there's this whole
complex signaling
circuit that's being established in
retinal ganglion cells after injury to
the optic nerve so the optic nerve is
damaged we're finding now that this is
giving rise to a signal a retrograde
signal to the retinal ganglion cells the
retinal ganglion cells are undergoing
kind of a storm that is changing the
environment of the entire retina
but it's cool saying glutamate to be
released
not just from normal synaptic vesicle
release but also the glutamate
transporter that normally accumulates
zinc in glial cells and in excitatory
into neurons that glutamate transporter
runs in Reverse because of this ionic
change in the retina giving rise to an
elevation of glutamate that elevation of
glutamate is activating NMDA receptors
on those elephant cells that produce
nitric oxide synthase that that is
causing an entry of calcium into those
cells calcium binds with calmodulin
activates nitric oxide synthase keeping
rise to this elevation is bursts of
nitric oxide which in turn is causing
zinc to be liberated from metallo Thea
names and then over time that zinc goes
over the began beam cells and is one of
the primary reasons but perhaps not the
exclusive reason that the ganglion cells
die and that ganglion cells fail to
regenerate their axons after optic nerve
injury so an important discovery was
made by Jeff Goldberg and Ben Darras at
the time working at Stanford University
Jeff is now the chairman of
ophthalmology at Stanford one of the
world leaders in this whole field of
retinal repair and Ben was one of the
greatest of all neuro scientists and
tragically died just a few months ago so
in this landmark paper what they showed
is that retinal ganglion cells during
development have an ability to extend
axons vigorously at early stages of
development
coinciding with the time that the visual
projections are first forming and then
at
by postnatal day 8 this capacity has
gone way down and you take these neurons
put them in a dish and they show very
little axon plug so the extent that axon
growth is mapped here as a function of
developmental time and so what Goldberg
and Barris and colleagues found is that
at during development during embryonic
development that these cells are
extending axons rapidly that capacity
goes way down postnatal them what they
asked the question of whether this loss
of growth ability is intrinsic to the
retinal ganglion cells or is it due to
interactions that occur between the
retinal ganglion cells and other neurons
of the retina that normally would start
forming connections with the retina it
necessarily postnatal period and to just
make this long story short what they
found is that the amacrine cells the
very cells that we discovered to
accumulate zinc and to suppress
excellent growth that way
Goldberg found that the membranes of
amacrine cells so this is a fairly
different phenomenon from the zinc but
just the mint membranes of an open cells
or in the whole cells about themselves
when mixed with retinal ganglion cells
in culture will shut off the ability of
retinal ganglion cells to extend axons
whereas when retinal ganglion cells are
mixed with all the other cells of the
retina retina here in the amercan so
depleted cultures this does not suppress
axon growth so this was really an
extraordinary finding saying that the
shutting off of a cell's ability to
growing after grow axons is not built-in
but it's due to their interaction with a
Makran cells but what we did was to use
a conditional cell deletion strategy to
remove the Amika cells from the retina
of adult animals and in brief what Fanny
John Fung in the lab has done recently
was to put the receptor for the
diphtheria toxin so called the theory of
toxin receptor through genetically
encoded in the cells of the retina and
throughout the body
and then that that gene becomes
activated as a stop codon that's removed
when you force those mice with other
mice that are expressing a cruel
accomodates
driven by a eloquent self specific
promoter so it's a V Gadd cream crossed
with the mice with the inducible the
theory toxin receptor and then that
atheria toxin receptor was all right so
the creamer combination gets turned on
it's the so called conditional curry
it's it's vegan curry and then after
that it has a tamoxifen receptor so when
you introduce tamoxifen or the estrogen
receptor when you introduce tamoxifen
you turn on the estrogen receptor
activates curry in those cells
predominates and it deletes the stop
codon that allows the diphtheria toxin
receptor to be introduced at that point
you then introduce the theory of toxin
and what Fanny found did you get this
amazingly selective loss of the outer
pit cells as we had hoped so this is the
normal complement of a merkin cells in
the retina and after this strategy this
conditional deletion of an open cells
we've lost 90% of all the applicant
cells and we strongly reduce by about 9%
the amercan cell receptors that can be
visualized with antibodies to either the
glycine transporter or the gaba
transporter in the synaptic layer and so
what does removing an open cells due to
retinal ganglion cells and what we find
is that this causes extraordinary
regeneration so what this is telling us
then is that just removal of into
neurons or removing the zinc that
accumulates it into neurons is a lot of
the nerve injury is a tremendously
potent of stimulus of regeneration or
conversely one could say that the inter
neurons are major suppressors of cell
survival and we general
so what have we learned from the optic
nerve that can be applied to other parts
in the central nervous system and so we
know that molecules like ANCA Magellan
are also playing a role in the so called
conditioning lesion effect that the
peripheral nervous system and central
nervous system for peripheral sensory
neurons
giganto has discovered a de insulin-like
growth factor 1 plus osteopontin first
discovered in the optic nerve system
also of course is axon regeneration in
the spinal cord I'll skip the other ones
in the interest of time we know that
blocking cell extrinsic suppressors of
axon growth can be partially effective
particularly when combined with other
strategies this has been shown in the
optic nerve and now has also been shown
in other parts of the central nervous
system including an activator of the so
called mTOR pathway that I didn't have a
chance to talk about today but also
activating the same pathway as p10
deletion various transcription factors
that activate downstream programs of
gene expression a number that were
discovered again in the optic nerve
system were found to be effective in the
spinal cord such as KL f7 klf4 and 9
from Jeff Goldberg's work have been
found to be important in in suppress
Jesus brought suppressors the back some
regeneration in the optic nerve blocking
receptors to the cell extrinsic
suppressor as a maximum growth is highly
effective again when combined with other
strategies to promote growth increasing
physiological activity at labs of Andy
Huberman and Chi Yu have taken this idea
in this case the idea goes from spinal
cord work to the optic nerve but this
also increases regeneration both systems
and now our discovery about the role of
presynaptic zinc in suppressing
regeneration you're just starting to
look at whether this can promote
regeneration in the spinal cord and and
then this crazy
we're moving into neurons who should be
trying to be central that was in the
brain spinal cord as well so in summary
then we know that intraocular
information combined with elevation of
cyclicamp E and p10 deletion enabled
some retinal ganglion cells to
regenerate their axons from the eye to
the brain with three innervation of some
central target areas and some simple
visual responses coming back and the
primary effect of the intraocular
information is mediated by uncle module
in but we know there are other molecules
as well the second point was about this
elevation of zinc in the inter neurons
its packaging in synaptic vesicles and
subsequent transfer to the retinal
ganglion cells the deletion of Z and T
through gene or using zinc key leaders
enables injured retinal ganglion cells
about here for them to survive long term
and maybe reduces optic nerve
regeneration that the upstream steps
vision elevation is this burst of nitric
oxide coming from other inter neurons of
the retina and what I didn't talk about
is that if we chelate the zinc we
uncover positive effects of nitric oxide
that are actually slimming that are
actually contributing to regeneration
and then and then this final point about
the adhesion of the inter neurons so
with that I'd like to thank you for your
attention and thank the people in my lab
we've done all of this work primarily
Virginians were the early stages by
splitting on Kwajalein and other
molecules associated with inflammation
only here are people in the last five or
ten years they were earlier
investigators from earlier work eric
eaching leads for the zinc work samara
for the combinatorial treatment at full
length regeneration and other very
important contributors to this work
people who worked on other projects in
the lab on spinal cord injury are the
role of inosine their childrenís from
the laboratory and then other
collaborators most importantly recently
Paul Rosenberg and all of the zinc and
nitric oxide work and our earlier work
in in inosine
collaborators from other Institute's
particularly as the apart and that went
by too fast and finally thank our
funding sources and thank you for your
attention and be happy to take questions
thank you dr. Benowitz for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's get started with our first
question of the day this question asks
can regenerating axons form a
topographic map a visual space onto the
brain so normal vision requires that
that the outside world gets represented
in an orderly fashion
onto the brain and through the work of
John Flanagan and others we know the
molecules that are responsible for the
formation of this highly organized map
of the visual world into into the brain
and so the question is can that be
recapitulated during regeneration and
the answer is we don't really know yet
clearly that's going to be important for
visual recovery if we to recover any any
kind of visual acuity so far what we're
seeing is that some excellence will go
back to their proper destinations and
that's enough to drive some genetically
encoded behaviors but that's not the
same as being able to make sense of
objects in the outside world or being
able to navigate in a in an environment
so that remains to be seen and I think
that's that's kind of one of the next
frontiers in this field excellent thank
you so much I can't write
no ganglion cells that have died be
replaced by stem cells so this is
another area of intense investigation up
until two or three years ago it had been
very difficult to induce stem cells to
differentiate into retinal ganglion
cells so we are as some successful cell
replacement is occurring in other parts
of the nervous system this had been
extremely difficult in the case of the
retina and and I should also mention
that this is not only important here
where we have traumatic injury to the
optic nerve but it's very important
clinically in the case of glaucoma and
some other degenerative diseases where
it is the retinal ganglion cells that
are dying and that that will need to be
replaced so several laboratories just in
the last two or three years the labs of
Jeff Goldberg Don Zack Tom Ray there may
be others that I'm forgetting have have
succeeded in getting some stem cells to
differentiate into retinal ganglion
cells and to get these cells to insert
themselves into the retina and begin
forming axons so this is very hopeful
that we may eventually be able to
replace lost retinal ganglion cells and
there were really two strategies say one
is induced pluripotent stem cells and
the other is using embryonic stem cells
from the from the immature retina so
research is occurring on both fronts and
there's been a little bit of progress in
both fronts so so this is looking very
hopeful excellent thank you so much our
next question asks are there additional
impediments to applying this research to
human patients well of course one is the
scale of the system the the optic nerve
in mice is maybe one centimeter total
from the eye to the brain and of course
in humans it's much much much higher
than that much much greater than that so
know that directly that we can scale up
what we have found in in mice and rats
but we are getting involved along with a
number of top colleagues around the
world trying to see if this research can
be applied to to larger mammals and at
this point this remains a kind of
empirical question but it's just now
starting and of course this is an
important intermediate step in being
able to treat patients eventually all
right thank you
bass sometime looks like we have time
for one last question today and this
question asks is zinc likely to
contribute to the failure of neurons to
generate axons in other parts of the
brain such as the spinal cord yeah so
this again is unknown it's it's really
not been studied yet so just now
sherry Peterson my group is starting to
look at this question what we know is
that unlike the retina which starts out
with very very low levels of freezing
and then shows this elevation and
increasing levels after the optic nerve
is injured the neocortex starts out with
extremely high levels of mobile zinc so
even if injury doesn't cause this
elevation presynaptic lis very high
levels of of ionic zinc are already
sitting in the synaptic terminals of
inter neurons in the cortex and it will
be very interesting to see if we chelate
that zinc or knock out the CM t3 gene
whether in fact we can increase the
amount of axon sprouting lorax of
regeneration we see if there injury to
the spinal cord
so yeah this so this too remains to be
seen well thank you once again
dr. Benowitz for your presentation I
would also like to thank blackbirds for
making today
educational webcast possible before we
go I love to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2018
you will receive an email friend
laggards letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live events for for now that's all thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again here soon at lab roots goodbye